me parece extraño que en halloween se
disfracen de la cultura de otras
personas
podríamos decir lo mismo sobre cualquier
disfraz le dirías a una niña que no
puede disfrazarse de pirata porque no
conoce su historia no es lo mismo pero
espectro invitamos a seis jóvenes
blancos estadounidenses para ver qué
opinaban
les pedimos que estuvieron de acuerdo
con algunos denunciados sobre raza
las personas blancas tienen cultura 3 2
todos somos blancos sin importar si
vienes de inglaterra australia o digamos
de sudáfrica venimos de diferentes
lugares y estamos rodeados de personas
de todas partes del mundo de las que
aprendemos pero eso no significa que
nosotros no tengamos cultura pero ser
blanco no es una cultura puedes tener
una cultura yo soy irlandés obviamente
esa es una cultura pero al ser solo
blanco
yo no puedo sentirme identificado
contigo solo porque seas blanca podría
decir lo mismo de cualquier grupo étnico
si todos aquí fuéramos negros me
identificaría con ustedes solo por el
color de nuestra piel y porque ellos
viven experiencias similares a ellos se
les discrimina por el color de la piel a
ti no se te va a discriminar ellos
pueden sentirse identificados con eso
creo que el estar en contacto con otras
culturas nos permite diversificar nos
probar cosas nuevas diferentes quizá
hemos perdido un poco de nuestra cultura
estamos creando una nueva cultura
creo en el racismo inverso
no sé qué le podemos explicar está bien
está bien me quedaré aquí antes de
decidir el racismo inverso se da cuando
alguien te discrimina por ser blanca
crees que alguien pudiera discriminar te
por ser blanca
si crecí en un lugar donde había muchas
personas hispanas se burlaban de mí
constantemente por ser blanca decían que
los blancos no sabíamos bailar que
éramos tontos y mucho más no deberían
decir eso creo que pero tenía que
decirlo siendo honesta eso no justifica
que me dijeran eso y muchas más cosas es
difícil de asimilar porque si me voltear
a y les dijera que las personas de color
no saben bailar me harían la vida
imposible pero si alguien me dice lo
mismo está bien porque eres muy
diferente anar me identifico contigo
porque al crecer mis amigos eran latinos
son negros tenía pocos amigos blancos y
se burlaban de mí por ser la chica
gringa no me lo tomaba personal porque
es una parte importante del racismo es
que está relacionado con el odio y la
opresión y como persona blanca en eeuu
no me sentía oprimida creo que debemos
ver primero nuestros propios defectos
antes de ver los defectos de los demás
estoy de acuerdo pero hay cosas que
corregir eso es lo que intento decir
siento que cualquier cosa que hagamos
puede parecer racista para las demás
razas al mismo tiempo si nos dicen algo
hiriente a nosotros y de su importancia
al pensar en la palabra racismo pienso
en opresión por eso estoy en desacuerdo
a lidiar con esas personas que solo se
quieren meter conmigo centrarnos en la
raza nos divide
creo que es importante centrarnos en la
raza de manera positiva para unirnos hay
un problema racial en eeuu y si lo
evitamos y fingimos como si no ocurriera
nada va a cambiar es mi opinión entendí
diferente la pregunta porque si lo único
que pienso es soy blanca y ella no soy
blanca y ella no para mí eso es
centrarse en la raza si nunca vamos a
ser felices hasta que trabajemos todos
juntos y nos tratemos los unos a los
otros como si no existiera la raza eso
suena bien pero no hemos llegado a ese
punto todavía sí creo que las personas
que dicen que no les importa el color de
piel e intentan no tener esa mentalidad
tampoco ayudan a nadie creo que debemos
respetar el bagaje cultural de los demás
y eso sólo ocurrirá si vemos las
diferencias de los demás
la apropiación cultural es real
sí creo que la apropiación cultural es
muy real la vemos en coachella aquí en
los ángeles
vemos personas con tocados al estilo de
los indios americanos sin saber lo que
representa para ellos sí exacto hay una
diferencia entre respetar la cultura o
faltarle el respeto por completo a la
cultura pero si quieres disfrazarse en
halloween de geisha porque te gusta el
disfraz o te parece bonito no creo que
sea yo no lo haría creo que si te vas a
disfrazar de geisha
sin conocer su importancia en el plan de
que lindo este disfraz me lo pondré y
aún se conoce la importancia y no lo sé
me parece extraño que en halloween se
disfracen de la cultura de otras
podríamos decir lo mismo sobre cualquier
disfraz le dirías a una niña que no
puede disfrazarse de pirata porque no
conoce su historia no es lo mismo
es diferente si son sólo niños tiene que
ver con la intención si regresamos al
ejemplo de coachella
la hora de acuerdo pensaría que esa
persona se está burlando de alguien aún
si no lo hacen de forma intencional
sigue siendo ofensivo debería poder
decir la palabra negro mientras cantó la
letra de una canción 3
la única razón por la que estoy en
desacuerdo es porque muchos de mis
raperos preferidos la utilizan con
frecuencia mi canción preferido de
chambers can be no la dice al menos una
siembra si vas a cantar cada dos
segundos hoy pensando en todas esas
cosas horribles acerca de las personas
de color
simplemente forman parte de la letra y
cuando canto se me sale existen
diferentes formas de usar la palabra y
depende de la intención y del uso
algunos me han dicho que si la uso con
respeto no voy a herir sus sentimientos
no es lo que habían dicho alguna
diversión en el auto y está sonando una
canción siento que no me corresponde
utilizarla si voy sola puede que la
susurren muy voz baja pero creo que por
respeto a las demás personas es mejor no
decirla y ya creen que debe dejar de
usar esa palabra en las canciones no
creo que si son afroamericanos y crees
que esta madre o que esté mal porque la
historia nos cuenta que los dueños de
esclavos usaban esa palabra para
referirse de manera despectiva a los
esclavos
y las personas de color quieren tomar
esa palabra y reivindicarla como suya y
reivindicar su dolorosa historia y
decirles a las demás personas saben que
no me importa usaré la palabra creo que
deberían poder hacerlo no tengo el
derecho como persona blanca de tomar una
palabra que ya era utilizada de manera
despectiva / es que agrediese a una
persona blanca canta la canción por eso
todos estamos de este lado las personas
de color usan esa palabra para referirse
entre ellos como ella dijo si ellos
quieren tomar la palabra y reivindicarla
me parece bien pero como persona blanca
no puedo evitar sentirme algo incómodo
tengo un sobrero onda sí sí los raperos
no la usarán ustedes no la dirían verdad
no así que hacen que digamos esa palabra
más a menudo ella no la diría si no
fuera por eso nos corresponde decirles
lo que pueden o no utilizar así que sí
tengo una vida privilegiada
traes 21
me entristece admitirlo no lo digo en
voz alta pero es cierto si me detuviera
la policía siento que tengo un poco de
ventaja porque soy blanca y porque soy
mujer me entristece que sea cierto pero
es algo que sucede y es lamentable creo
que yo no me siento una persona
privilegiada claro que la historia nos
dice que los blancos son superiores a
los demás pero yo también he vivido
cosas muy difíciles no me siento
superior a otras personas así que no
creo ser una persona privilegiada si
tengo una vida privilegiada es decir no
me siento superior a los demás pero sí
creo que se me trata diferente es solo
cuestión sí creo que existe una
concepción errónea tengo privilegios que
no he pedido pero la sociedad me ve como
un estándar por alguna razón y por eso
se me trata de forma diferente el
privilegio blanco como dijiste no tiene
que ver con lo que has vivido sino que
tiene que ver con la forma en la que el
mundo tv
estoy orgulloso de ser blanco 321
puedo estar en el medio y guayabero
medio
está bien debes elegir un lado elijo
lado no sé qué lado escoger ayúdame
culpable por lauro ligeramente en
desacuerdo estar feliz de que no me
hayan oprimido pero no me siento
orgullosa de lo valioso la gente en el
pasado me siento orgulloso de algo por
lo que he tenido que trabajar duro no sé
no hice nada para ser blanco
corbijn en desacuerdo absolutamente nada
tampoco se me quitó nada por ser blanco
decir que estás orgulloso de ser blanco
es completamente diferente a decir que
estás orgulloso de ser de color cuando
escucho a alguien decir que está
orgulloso de ser de color
pienso en empoderamiento fuerza valentía
y muchas más cosas maravillosas que las
personas de color han logrado estos
últimos años pero si dices que estás
orgulloso de ser una persona blanca
pareciera que ya hay mucho güey odio y
la renta sería diferente lo que pasa es
que como dijiste cuando alguien dice que
está orgulloso de ser de color tiene que
ver con empoderamiento porque no puedo
decir que es
orgulloso de tu color de piel porque eso
está mal diciendo que no puedo estar
orgullosa de ser blanca porque no tengo
cultura no eso no es lo que estoy
diciendo cuando se enorgullecen de ser
blancas muchas veces al menos en mi
opinión están hablando de su color de
piel y de que no son una raza diferente
creo que eso está mal si bien como
estábamos diciendo a las personas de
color se les ha oprimido y se les ha
robado gran parte de su cultura muchas
de las razones por las que no estoy
orgulloso de ser blanco es porque por
los nazis lo observan y el el ku klux
klan también no quiero que se me asocie
con ninguno de los dos así que
simplemente me mantendré al margen claro
que no estoy orgullosa de lo que he
hecho mi cultura pero al mismo tiempo no
querría ser otra cosa si tuviera que
elegir otra raza no sabría cuál estoy
satisfecha con lo que soy aunque recibe
una reacción negativa por ser blanca
[Música]
no hay pregunta sobre comida estaba
esperando hablar de comida te gusta me
encantó conocerlos muy bien hola chicos
soy john y yo soy gering muchas gracias
por ver este episodio de aspecto
esperamos que hayan disfrutado del
debate de hoy háganos saber su opinión a
través de los comentarios
si quieren ver más de nuestros vídeos no
olviden suscribirse a nuestro canal nos
vemos pronto
you believe